can you repeat the question one more
time I think I don't know gosh
sorry I remember I feel bad calling my
family out we were at the DMV once and
my mom made a comment about well you're
in America you should speak English
because someone was speaking to their
family member and I think in Middle
Eastern language and I correct her I was
like America doesn't have a national
language we're a nation of immigrants
within like the Hispanic community a
common comment that's brought up is that
they don't want their daughters and sons
to marry or date black people a lot of
the times there's a sense of humor
behind that that is just a joke or it's
harmless and it's not serious but to me
even if it is a joke it's not a joke
that's funny I love my entire family I'm
actually the only one who is in support
of the black lives matter movement and
it is very difficult to talk to my
family one thing that I want to do is to
get together and perhaps have like a
movie night and suggest for example 13th
that does explore the concept of
systemic racism let the people know
around you
the current effects of like colonization
and the attitude that we've all gotten
kind of from being taught through an
entire lens of white supremacy everybody
thinks of it as kind of a past thing I
remember the first slur when I was like
4 or 5 these guys were like your skin
looks like poop you know you just melt
like [ __ ] we don't know playing with you
you're the color of [ __ ] so it was kind
of like okay I knew from very young that
I was gonna encounter
you know these attitudes I think there
is internalized racism because racism is
a systematic we get indoctrinated with
it so Allah I see a lot of colorism
lighter brighter better so the closer
you are to whiteness whether it's hair
whether it's the way you speak or you
know I see I see some of that black
people who are around people that seek
to practice anti blackness bu
unapologetically the more you practice
that the more you the more you put
yourself out there without any qualms or
asking questions the more it forces
those people to see you and to see
themselves as a result in Hispanic
culture we refer to some African
Americans as negative thoughts and
that's a very derogatory just verbage
that is common where we're from in our
village where I came from and immigrated
from being in this country as an
immigrant and now luckily being able to
be a daca recipient and a dreamer the
conversation I talked to my parents
about is you know I you have to have a
conversation with me about police
because what that means for me being
deported possibly one day but African
American kids have to have this
conversation about their skin color
which they had no decision of listening
to black people when we talk about
anything that makes us uncomfortable if
someone in your inner circle is saying
the n-word and not thinking you're
overreacting or thinking we're
overreacting for being offended by it
don't let it slide just because that
person is your friend my high school was
predominantly white people and white
people saying the n-word was very common
and no teacher or a dolt really
questioned it when addressing someone
who is races racist is to address them
as hard as it is with a little bit more
compassion and kindness I think when you
address someone boldly and attack them
then they're just on defense mode and
not willing to listen kind of
approaching it on more of a level of
love helps people to be a little bit
more
oh that's hard to man if you have to
explain that what you're saying is an
erase joke maybe you shouldn't be saying
it yeah so actually it was toward
someone a person of color and they
mentioned that they had to be in the
back of the restaurant because of their
color and I did mention it to a manager
actually about how I did feel
uncomfortable about certain things being
said and it actually kind of felt like
it was being brushed off and actually
led me to leave the company being paid
less than their white counterparts
I know it's very the rule that they tell
you in the workplace is not to discuss
wages I think if people can push for a
more transparent conversations to have
in the workplace that's a good way to be
in a lie and make sure everyone is being
treated and compensated fairly so I
think there's a lot of training as far
as sexual harassment goes and quarterly
misconduct within the workforce but I
don't think there's a lot of training
videos that touch base on just on racism
so they had a full day worth of training
and in this training someone opened up
in that conversation and she was saying
how she's a white woman who has a son
who's a white male a teenager and she
has recently been so fearful of how he's
interpreting everything in the way that
he might be exposed to a group of people
who have a mindset that you know black
lights don't matter
it got her so emotional that she was in
tears because she was asking for help
how do i educate my son to make sure he
understands this and just by having that
conversation you know it opened up a lot
of doors I am in the holistic field so I
teach yoga many
breathwork and in this field you see a
lot of advertisements you see a lot of
the teachers who are prominent with
large followings there they're white I
feel that if we're going to share
culture that there should be an
amplification of black voices just
because they've been actively suppressed
it's seen as unprofessional to have
braids or to have twists and those are
protective styles of black women and men
black women are three to four times more
likely than white women to die in
childbirth and that's because there's
these stereotypes that black women are
strong and aggressive compared to white
women being fragile and feminine and so
it really has an impact on how black
people express their pains and how its
received by health care professionals it
is important to listen and you want to
listen with the intent to understand a
lot of times people listen with the
intent to reply to everything and we
just want to be understood we have to
put defenses down and stop assuming that
racism is a problem for other people but
you yourself can never be racist I think
that's the most harmful idea to have an
easy thing that every individual can do
is to vote you know on your local level
your local government on for the
presidential election I seek to make
people that feel anti blackness that are
that are struck by the sight of it or
the existence of it I seek to make those
people uncomfortable because that
uncomfortability ultimately leads to
them asking the important questions
there was a certain point that I just do
not I was not a track I didn't was not
sexually attracted to like black folks
like black men and
I think it's because of the implicit
bias that I had growing up I try to
recognize we're done myself in certain
situations and I try to fight against it
if you want to see is police brutality a
problem you can just look it up it's
right there
America it's oftentimes the real color
that they see is green and if we can
research where we put our money and see
what they're doing with it who are they
donating it to are they can using your
money to oppress black people then you
need to take your dollars and put it
into companies that are more progressive
I'm sorry I thought I had so many good
things to say use whatever privilege you
can to amplify black voices they say I
talk with like oh you're the whitest
black girl I've ever met
and I hate it I've always hated it but
in the moment I'm like hahaha but it's
not okay being brave that sounds
probably silly but I think it can be
really really hard to have conversations
like this and just taking the first step
of like opening it up even when it's
really uncomfortable anti racism is not
a one day thing it is something that
will take the rest of our lives even
after all of the media has gone down
even after all the protesters have gone
away even when there's no one no longer
saying it we still have to live it we
have to live it every day
don't just say black lives matter live
black lives matter
[Music]